we'll need to pass in some values in
order to meaningfully discuss this
question so let's make some here
furthermore I'm going to make the
variable names reflect the color of the
value that they store at this point now
that we have some values we can finally
call the function passing in a couple of
the objects that we've made so we can
see how they're treated input parameters
to a function only have bindings when
that function is actually running so
only now that we have an example of
invocation can we really meaningfully
evaluate what we expect parameter to to
be bound to so what do you expect to be
logged in this example